[Music]
so we're back with the rematch with the
fast-talking rook winning Sebastian
Mahina up against the rook plundering
world champion Ariane tari who is trying
to get his revenge there is no reason
not to get going I'm excited to see this
[Music]
let's talk more play don't give up your
bishop fair now I didn't give up the
bishop pair back and we're gonna get
opposite colored bishops and he's going
to try and fly okay know from experience
that Audriana is very fast and very
strong so this will not be easy for the
fast-talking ruining young Sebastian oh
[Music]
that is ugly let's see if I can invade
Amba on the dark squares or if it simply
does not care and he just wants to win
that time she's trying to it on time
exchanging the Queen's going for the
opposite color Bishop ending now the
people got a move pieces that are close
to the clock that is what you gotta do
ion is collapsing I have to say but now
he's she is cutting the speech and what
are the time situations mr. head of
screaming what are we looking at here
this is gonna be very exciting
now one thing is for sure there are not
going to be any drawers we're playing to
Last Man Standing
[Music]
it's a million times repetition now but
it doesn't matter in bullying chest
this position is add that in one time
well that was now we got one one and we
will be let back later with Armageddon
game
[Music]